nos tripes les normes de maternelle 4
ans c'est un groupe plus pour les
enfants en particulier les enfants qui
ont des difficultés tant pour le gault
at il raison de dire que le nombre de
classes de maternelle 4 ans a triplé
pendant son mandat
oui mais la caq a tout de même brisé sa
promesse de la dernière campagne
électorale
en 2018 on comptait près de 400 classes
de maternelle 4 ans au québec et ce
nombre devrait grimper à un peu plus de
1600 cette année selon les projections
du ministère de l'éducation
on peut donc assurément dire que sa
triple voire quadruple et pendant les
quatre dernières années mais
l'engagement de la caq était beaucoup
plus ambitieux le gouvernement de la cac
va sur cinq ans implanté partout des pré
maternelle 4 ans ben voie disponible
pour tous les enfants de 4 ans
en 2018 la cac avait promis d'ouvrir
5200 classe dans un horizon de 5 ha mais
l'année suivante le gouvernement legault
a abaissé cette cible à 2006 en classe
en prévoyant un taux de fréquentation de
50 % en ce moment près de 16000 enfants
sont en maternelle quatre ans le taux de
fréquentation et donc de 18% pour
laquelle de vos promesses électorales
êtes vous prêt à prendre l'engagement de
démissionner de votre poste si vous ne
la respectez pas pour moi là je fais de
la politique seulement pour la
maternelle catherine vous mettiez votre
poste en jeu votre siège en jeu gratuit
oui les 2600 classe devrait finalement
être ouverte en 2025 deux ans plus tard
que prévu
la caq a aussi sous-estimé les coûts de
construction d'une classe de maternelle
4 à d'abord évaluée à 120 mille dollars
aujourd'hui le coût de construction
moyen d'une classe tous niveaux
confondus est plutôt d'un million deux
cent mille dollars ces dix fois plus
élevé